[MUSIC]
Take a moment and picture your favorite
childhood bicycle.
What did it look like?
What color was it?
Did you have one of those weird banana
seats that used to be so popular?
Or perhaps you were the creative type with
cards in your spokes and
streamers coming from your handlebar.
My bike was a bright red Schwinn with a
cushy black seat and
these sweet pegs on my front wheel.
[LAUGH] I rode my bike everywhere as a
child,
to school, to my friend's house, to the
pool.
I even rode it on an ill-fated attempt to
run away from home.
[LAUGH] You see as children, without a car
or a drivers license, it is
the bike that provides with the ultimate
sense of freedom and independence.
Now think back to your most recent
interaction with a bike.
When was it?
What were you doing?
Perhaps you commuted to campus today on a
bike, or maybe you went for
a ride on the curvy roads of coastal
California.
As adults, the bike provides us with a
different type of freedom.
Freedom from work, freedom from stress,
freedom from routine.
The bike scratches our itch for adventure,
and
pri, provides us with a brief escape from
reality.
I've been riding bikes my entire life.
For a period of time, I even raced
mountain bikes professionally,
on the World Cup circuit.
It's easy for many of us to view the bike
through the lens of a child,
a weekend warrior, or maybe even a
professional.
But a few years ago, I began to wonder if
there's something more to the bike.
What if that freedom that a bike provides
is more impactful than just
the independence of a child?
Or the exercise of an adult?
What if the bike could inspire us to
tackle some of the world's most
complex problems?
Allow me to take you on a bit of a
journey.
It's July 2009 in a tiny village in rural
Zambia.
Belita, a 15 year old girl who lives in
the village,
wakes up before dawn to feed her family's
chickens before school.
Belita commutes daily to Chalala Basic
school.
Three miles away over unmaintained dirt
roads.
Belita, unlikely many of us, Belita does
not have access to a car or a school bus.
So Belita has to make this long walk on
foot.
Now let's think about this for a second.
Three miles, on foot, every day, each
direction.
That's like walking from this classroom to
the Dutch Goose, twice a day,
barefoot on dirt roads on the hottest day
of the year in Palo Alto.
I also don't think there is a juicy
hamburger and
GSP phone at the end of this road.
But seriously, how good would your school
attendance be if you
had to walk that far to get to school?
I'll have to admit, I don't think mine
would be very good.
On this particular day, it takes Belita 90
minutes to get to school.
By the times she arrives, she is late, and
she's fatigued from the long commute.
Belita didn't have time that morning to
complete her homework before school, so
she quickly falls behind.
Belita attends school only three days a
week.
Her academic performance is low.
Now let me ask you.
What do you think would happen if Belita,
if we gave Belita a bike?
Fast forward to 2011 in the same tiny
village in rural Zambia.
Belita wakes up before dawn to feed her
family's chickens before school.
Belita then collects her new bike
that she recently received from World
Bicycle Relief,
a charity organization that delivers
purpose-built bikes in places like Zambia.
The three-mile commute to, to school takes
only 20 minutes on a bike.
So Belita arrives on time, prepared, with
energy to focus.
Belita now attends school five days a week
and her academic performance is soaring.
The bike has reinvigorated Belita's energy
towards life and
she's now on track to achieving her life
long dream of becoming a nurse.
You know,
Scientific American once published a
really great study that determined which
animal species consumed the least energy
to travel a fixed distance.
Point a to point b.
We're talking efficiency of motion.
Perhaps not surprisingly, the condor,
with its ability to soar on its huge
ten-foot wingspan, ranked number one.
The human strolled across the finish line.
An underwhelming third of the way down the
list.
Turns out we're not designed for speed or
efficiency.
We are, however, quite adept at overcoming
our deficiencies using our brains.
Researchers then reran the study providing
the human with a single tool.
You got it, a bike.
With the aid of a bike, the human rose all
the way to the top of the list,
above the condor, as the most efficient
animal species on the planet.
Behold, human creativity and the power of
the bicycle.
My friends, the bike is an incredibly
powerful tool.
With the aid of a bicycle a human can
carry five times as much weight and
can travel four times faster than a person
on foot.
That trip to the market that once yielded
40 pounds of rice now yields 200.
That hour and a half commute is now 20
minutes.
These statistics are staggering.
Staggering enough to be life changing for
Belita and
others who do not have access to modern
forms of transportation.
Studies have proven,
that in places like Zambia, a bike can
increase academic performance by 60%.
That's the difference between a GMAT score
of 440, and a GMAT score of 700.
[LAUGH] I don't need to get the dean down
here to tell you how meaningful that is.
[LAUGH]
The bike has the power
to free people from poverty, now that is
what I call freedom.
But not only is the bike a really powerful
tool, it's also a very simple tool.
Two wheels, pedals, handlebar, and a seat,
connected by a simple metal frame.
You can even take a class here at Stanford
where you learn to build your very own
bike from scratch.
And the bike is old technology.
The bike was invented in Germany in 1817
and
much of the original construction has
remained unchanged in the last 200 years.
Look, I don't mean to suggest that the
bike is without its challenges.
We need to fix flat tires.
And repair used bikes.
But if we can overcome these small
hurdles, we have such an incredible tool.
A bike is powerful, and yet it's simple.
A bike has the ability to meaningfully
improve huge global problems like
illiteracy, poverty, and hunger.
But basic transportation is just is, is
the bike's core competency.
And basic transportation is only one of
thousands of
big hairy problems we face in our world
today.
Can we take what we've learned from the
bike and
apply it to these other issues as well?
I think so.
You know, here at Stanford,
we're encouraged to tackle big problems
and change our world for the better.
While inspiring, this mandate is also
daunting.
I find myself wondering,
why am I more qualified than the many
brilliant minds that came before me?
Do I need signif, significant financial
resources to even begin?
I don't know about you, but
I often feel overwhelmed by the enormity
of our world's problems.
Fix poverty, cure cancer, eradicate
malaria.
I can feel my anxiety levels rising
already.
My overwhelmed mind wants to give up
before I've even begun.
The bike though has become my source of
inspiration.
When I'm feeling overwhelmed by an
impossibly complicated task, I
think back to Belita and the impact that a
humble everyday bike has had on her life.
I gain confidence knowing that incremental
solutions to some of Zambia's
worst problems, don't require a rocket
scientist or a billion dollars.
The bike is a great example of how a
simple tool
can have a profound impact on our world.
Maybe I am up to the task, and maybe you
are too.
I'll leave you with this.
Sometimes we don't need billion dollar R
and D budgets to tackle big problems.
All we need is creativity and a bit of
perspective.
World Bicycle Relief is changing the world
through the power of the bicycle.
What other everyday tools are we
overlooking?
Simple, sustainable solutions exist for
many of the world's most complex problems.
In some cases, a meaningful solution may
be parked in your garage with
a flat tire in a thin coat of dust.
All you have to do is reimagine its
potential.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC]